Congress is going on recess after an
explosive week on Capitol Hill but the
impeachment inquiry and accusations of a
White House cover-up are just getting
started
President Trump is responding by lashing
out at Democrats and the official who
complained about his phone call with
Ukraine's president he calls a
whistleblower sources quote close to a
spy
the president's Acting Director of
National Intelligence spent hours
answering questions from the House and
Senate intelligence committees yesterday
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
with Congress going home for a couple of
weeks what happens to impeachment well
there are several new names Anthony in
this whistleblower report so
congressional investigators are going to
be working to line up interviews with
them and Democrats actually see that
time at home as very valuable because
they want to get the poll numbers for
impeachment up and so they're gonna need
to make the case directly to their
constituents this whistleblower has
given us a road map for our
investigation Democrats say this nine
page whistleblower report has handed
them their strongest case yet for
impeachment judgment some hope to vote
by the end of this year at a three-hour
hearing after you Director of National
Intelligence Joseph McGuire called the
whistleblowers complaint incredible
I think the whistleblower did the right
thing I think he followed the law every
step of the way the whistleblower
describes conversations with more than
half a dozen US officials who were
deeply disturbed by the president's
foreign phone call in which he sought to
pressure the Ukrainian leader to
investigate former Vice President Joe
Biden some Republicans were troubled too
I want to say to the president this is
not okay it isn't that conversation is
not okay but it's what the whistleblower
says happened in the days following the
call that has rocked Capitol Hill quote
senior White House officials intervened
to lock down all records of the phone
call removing a summary of the
conversation from the normal computer
system and storing it in a classified
system where few people would see it
according to White House officials this
was not the first time this is a
cover-up
this is a cover-up many Republicans
questioned the whistleblowers claims I
think the most immediate concern I have
is it does not based on first-hand
knowledge in other words he says he
heard this from other people but the
republican-led Senate Intelligence
Committee is now investigating the
scandal - and grilled McGuire behind
closed doors on Thursday this will
generate more questions than we asked
today the identity of this whistleblower
is being closely guarded even Acting DNI
McGuire said he doesn't know the
person's name and doesn't want to
congressional investigators from both
the Senate and House Intelligence
Committee are still working to line up
an interview with that person they're
working through the legal issues that so
that's another thing that's gonna go on
Tony during the two-week break all right
Nancy thank you very much